hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes we were just wrapping up
this week's episode when we learned the
sad news that queen elizabeth ii has
died
after seven decades on the throne
so we're going to start the program by
talking about the late queen
and i am joined now by charles moore
who's a former editor of the spectator
as well as a former editor of the daily
telegraph and the sunday telegraph and
we're also joined by james forsyth who
is our political editor
charles it's been um 70 years
since uh british monarch died um i
appreciate it's before your time 1952
but um perhaps using your historical
knowledge you could give us a sense of
what a different country britain was
and the different position the monarchy
was in
uh when queen elizabeth the second
acceded to the throne
i think it's a bit misrepresented what
happened then
people now think of it as incredibly
old-fashioned and which in a way it was
but in another way it wasn't because
what it was was the recovery
of confidence um
and
uh ceremony after the horrors of the
second world war and it was of course a
very young monarch
so people were very excited in
it's also the first television event
big public event on television in
british british history
and so it seemed very new though its
ritual was very ancient
um
and the fact that a
very young woman had become queen and in
fact become queen while
having holiday in uh kenya um was also
part of
this this is a new thing hard to think
of that now it now seems
almost prehistoric when you watch the um
the the uh film but um it wasn't like
that at the time
yes the television uh aspect of her
reign is very important isn't it it's
hard to uh think of elizabeth ii without
thinking about television and so
i think british people actually started
to buy television so that they could see
the queen is that not right that is
correct yes and not many people had
television still so enormous numbers of
people i remember frank johnson the
spectator's former editor it was an east
end boy telling me about how they were
crowded into his uncle's house in
shoreditch and sort of 40 of them all
sat around watching and they could
hardly see anything because a tiny tiny
screen poor film but terribly exciting
to watch it
james um
there's already uh
some anxiety that uh the queen who was
this great unifying figure for the union
uh is now gone uh and that the glue that
bound the nation together if you like uh
is is is now has now vanished um
do you think union is the right to be
concerned about the future
uh the queen obviously
uh acted as a kind of great unifying
force and i think the
mourning for her uh will will be
testament to that but i do think the
unifying figure of the monarchy will
will remain in
in a different way in a different form i
think i think i think for king charles
it will be different fro than it was for
her
but i think i think he has uh he comes
to the crown
relatively late in life he's in his 70s
and i think he will he will bring
uh that experience and i think he is
wise enough to know
that as king he will have to be uh to be
more private about his opinions than he
was as prince of wales charles are we
about to see that um because of course
everybody talks about how queen
elizabeth represented continuity are we
about to see that monarchy itself
represents continuity even more so
perhaps than late green
i think so i think um
you shouldn't uh talk of the queen as um
as if it's a sort of
one-off special
thing
and she would have been the last person
in the world who have wanted to see it
that way the point of the monarchical
system is that it's dynastic and all its
efforts go into perpetuating itself um
uh it has no other means of um survival
and the queen did that triumphantly um
both in terms of breeding so that we've
got this line stretching out before us
for you know what might be 100 years
never happened before um but also in
terms of making the right provision so
for example she was very careful to
ensure quite recently actually that
then prince of wales would become head
of the commonwealth when she died
um she carefully
worked all that out
so
i don't expect the crisis of monarchy
what i do think is
will obviously be difficult in the short
term is that a whole way of thinking
about british monarchy
has been very governed by this reign
because it's so successful and so long
and um
some rethinking will require i'll just
make one point there which is that now
that the queen is dead the person with
the by far the longest experience of
public life anywhere in the whole of the
world
is the new king
he has been um he's been an active
figure on the international stage for
more than 50 years
james what do you think was the most uh
precarious moment perhaps of elizabeth's
reign because there were moments of
christ crisis crises
uh in the 70s and 80s um
what where do you where do you think she
had her most difficult period as monarch
i i think there are two uh 1992 the
anna's herbalist and then 1997 are after
the death of diana princess of wales
when i i mean the queen and her desire
to to protect understandable disaster
protect her own family
kind of misread the public mood and
uh and i think i think in some ways
that was that was a very difficult
moment for the monarchy given how
emotionally volatile the country was at
that point but i think what stands out
to me is that in this 70 year reign that
the the longest in british history you
know those uh
though those mistakes are so much
smaller than the equivalent mistakes
made by queen victoria when you think
about the the bed chamber crisis
or um or queen victoria's withdrawal
from public life after prince albert's
death
charles do you do you think um after the
death of diana and obviously there was a
little tumult there uh that queen
elizabeth uh and the monarchy in fact
came out stronger because of it
i do think so i think it was um
it was difficult but really the profound
difficulty lasted for five days it was
from the princess died on a sunday the
trouble began on a monday and the queen
calmed it by her broadcast on the friday
and the funeral was the following day
and um actually um
the queen was perhaps slow off the mark
in seeing exactly how you would need to
deal with this question but when she did
see in this very very short period she
got absolutely right on that friday with
her broadcast and brought the nation
together in time for the funeral so
i don't think even if if she got that
wrong it would have been ultimately
disastrous and i said he didn't agree
with the people at the time or later who
say that it's written demonically but i
think um
it was it was difficult it did show up
some real problems um
and it was the nearest we ever got to
quite strong public criticism of the
queen um
all those things were important but all
those things were overcome
charles i wanted to end by asking you
about the queen's faith uh because she
was
a devout christian in an age that uh is
often called post-christian
um how important do you think was
religion to the way the queen looked at
the world and the way the queen behaved
as a monarch
i think it was absolutely central to the
queen's approach
and not only because she took her role
as supreme governor of church of england
very seriously
but for more profound uh
reasons um that was her faith
um and she had a particular type of
christian faith which is very acquired
but is all pervading so each day um
she prayed every night and she each
sunday she attended church
and she was very much of that school i
think which doesn't want to talk about
it but does want to do it
and to practice this more than to preach
whenever she did preach which is very
very slightly at her christmas broadcast
the name of jesus would usually come in
and the christmas message in some way
would always come in a christian message
at christmas and um
i think it explains the way she did so
much by stealth
you have to think in order to understand
the queen you have to understand
uh the
things you didn't quite see or that she
didn't quite say as much as the things
that she did and
that's very characteristic of a certain
humble christianity which is you're not
showing off you don't matter as yourself
it's your duty to god in your neighbor
that matters and that's that gives uh
life's lifelong
sustaining power
do you think her religious instincts
were perhaps more low church than uh you
might expect from a head of the church
um
maybe but i i think it's very important
that the queen didn't have
was absolutely uninterested in religious
parties and factions in fact um you know
would have regarded them as a very very
bad news and um this also explains
attitude to other faiths
um and other denominations of
christianity um
nobody could ever she was a strong quite
old-fashioned protestant anglican
but nobody could ever say she was trying
to sort of advance that in some
argumentative or disparaging way against
anyone else and she famously
formulated the doctrine that the church
of england could be a sort of umbrella
for other denominations and other faiths
and i that was very clearly recognized
by jews and muslims and so on um
she she understood that
um
if she was going to follow in the
footsteps of jesus which in her quiet
way she was trying to do
she must always show love and respect
for people not
be disapproving of them
james we now have a new king
and
britain will now have to think about the
role of the church of england
in uh public life
do you think we will now see a monarchy
that has to concentrate more on its on
the religious aspect and and the sacred
aspects of it
i i think the coronation will obviously
bring those things to the fore
uh i i think though that uh
as charles said i think i think the
church of england has it is the church
of the country and i think that i think
the royal family's done a very astute
job of you know
for all the divisions within the
anglican communion on all sorts of
issues the royal family's done a very
astute job of of avoiding getting drawn
into those
charles
you knew the queen a little bit uh
there's going to be a lot of talk about
her character what she was really like
and so on but i wonder if you could tell
us uh is there an aspect of her
personality that you think
the public uh misses
well no i think i think her integrity
was
apparent what i think it perhaps needs
emphasis
which i find in a way the most
extraordinary thing about it is
her absolute lack of vanity
um here you are um
all your life and certainly from when
you knew you were going to be uh
out of the throne people have been
flattering you
every single day
so she probably has received flattery
for
96 years i don't think one little bit of
it went to her head i didn't think she
ever thought aren't i clever aren't i
brilliant gosh didn't i do well aren't i
beautiful etc none of really none of
those things at all she had an inner
dignity and therefore an inner
self-confidence
but literally no vanity and that's the
most extraordinary achievement i think i
can't think of anyone famous who's like
that
charles james thank you very much indeed
[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes my name is freddie gray and i
will be your host today
you may have heard that britain has a
new prime minister so we're going to
spend this episode uh talking about
whether britain is ready to be led by
liz truss and whether liz trust is ready
to lead britain
i will talk to james forsyth and katie
balls about the political situation and
liz truss's first few days
i will also talk to julian jessup and
hamish mcrae about trustonomics can it
possibly work
and we will round out our politics
section by talking about the legacy of
boris johnson who left office this week
i'll be joined by andrew jimson
we'll then move internationally to look
at the bubbling war over microchips
between america
and china
and we will round off uh by talking to
everybody's favorite columnist rod
little
about the bbc and bias
first of all i'm very pleased to be
joined by the spectators political
editor james forsyth and the spectators
deputy political editor katie balls and
we're going to be analyzing
liz truss's first week
uh james i'll start with you
it's hard to think of a prime minister
who started uh with such low
expectations uh surrounding them
uh this could of course be an advantage
for liz trust do you think she will
benefit from the fact that uh the
general mood in about politics and about
britain at the moment is so gloomy
yeah i think there is there is a paradox
of the situation that she finds herself
in which is she comes in with you know
delete as appropriate you know the worst
entree since you know 1066 of any prime
minister
but there is there is a plus side to her
for that which is there are a few
moments when the public look to politics
and and really pay attention and this is
one of them people want to know what is
happening to their energy bills people
want to know what the government is
going to do so liz trust who is for
someone who has been a senior politician
for quite some time is relatively
unknown to the public there isn't a a
view of her formed among voters yet i
think i think things are still in flux
she has a chance to introduce herself to
show that she can be decisive to show
that she can offer leadership
and i i think that is an opportunity i
think that you know this is
she she she has the nation's attention
right now
do you think the fact that she's not
slick james sticking with you do you
think the fact that she's not seen as
slick and that rishi shouldn't that was
often betrayed as slick you know perhaps
unfairly sometimes um but do you think
that public perception is actually
advantageous with britain because
british people don't really like
slickness
i i think what liz ross will try and do
is make a virtue of it she does this
thing of saying you know what you see is
what i with me what you see is what you
get you know she emphasizes that she's
not the best presenter um but but i
think that what she will try and do but
i think also it is worth remembering
that you know her
public she's also i think a confidence
politician when things are going well
for her she gets better i think you saw
that during the tour leadership contest
in the in the first debate when the
parliamentary rounds were proving very
difficult for her she didn't turn in a
great performance as things got better
you know that royal jelly of confidence
began to to to have its effect
and she became better and better and you
saw in her speech outside downing street
you know that she did what she needed to
do uh at prime minister's questions she
turned you know she was in command of a
house and you know she is going to take
a very different approach to boris
johnson boris johnson was you know lots
of bluster liz ross answered the
questions at pmq's and actually chose to
put kind of clear ideological blue water
between her and kia stallman kierstarma
went on pushing her on a windfall tax
liz trust was adamantly against it now
there is obviously a risk in that in
that the polling suggests that even
conservative voters are in favor of
another windfall tax we should say
because there already is one in place
but i i think you see here but she is
she is uh on on on that kind of question
she is willing to enter into an
ideological argument obviously the
energy policy that she is uh announced
on thursday you know that is about as
far from a free market position as you
can get and that i think shows that she
is this intriguing mix of uh ideological
and pragmatic
katie uh we have uh a new cabinet and
two things struck me uh looking at the
new cabinet the first one was that um
almost every single woman on there has
been on your podcast women with balls
uh so i recommend all respect tv
listeners viewers uh tune in to katie's
podcast the second is what everybody
said which is that it seems to be a case
of loyalty has been rewarded um is this
a very tight pack
so i think when you look at the cabinet
that she has assembled as you say
loyalty is the key word and i think
there's also to a degree because rishi
sunak and this trust were
so apart when it came to the economic
debate of what we saw in the contest so
members his supporters suggesting
dominic electoral suicide know was what
her
tax cuts would mean and i think the view
of the of team trust is effectively it's
quite hard to have people who've gone so
hard against the plans to suddenly be in
senior roles going on media rounds
having to defend her government's
message so i i think that was one of the
factors but also she she wants those who
have you know backed from the beginning
or you know had taken on
difficult situations to do so to be
rewarded and you can see that running
through and i think when you look more
widely at how that is going to work
there is some more reaching out in the
junior and ministerial ranks and some
russia's unique supporters robert
generic and was brought in which i think
is intended to say
we you know we're not completely closed
uh there is a way back but ultimately
you need to get on board of course when
things start to get quite tricky for liz
trust this might not feel like a
honeymoon yet but this effectively is
her honeymoon stage and it may be the
other way around the sense she will have
to do be doing more to get people to
back her rather than you know
expecting people to come to her
she does have uh a few loyalists already
but um it's also probably fair to say
this quite she has quite a few enemies
within the tory party are you picking up
a lot of resentment and animosity
so i'm not sure if it's resentment but i
think there's definitely a lack of
enthusiasm in lots of parts of the party
towards this trust and ultimately she
she had you know the lowest mp support
um
if you think by compared to predecessors
so theresa may boris johnson both won
the highest number of mps in the
parliamentary round rishi soon equine in
hers shows that she didn't have great
parliamentary support now she then
overtook him but i do think if uh mp's
back you when all the polls suggest
you're storming ahead it's not quite as
sincere as doing it early on and walking
around parliament speaking to mps uh
lots of families are pretty damn beat
they're
not particularly inspired but at the
same time i think everyone's so drained
from how long this tory leadership
contest has gone on for um and also just
how brutal the last few months boris
johnson's leadership were that at the
moment i don't get the sense that it's
turning into lots of scheming about you
know
ways to get her out and so forth and
actually is perhaps more that mps have
just resigned to the fact they don't
have a leader from how they particularly
agree with now that could bubble up on
lots of issues as time goes on and but
yeah i think that is more the mood at
the moment
james do you think there's an appetite
in the tory party for a bit of unity for
once uh i mean certainly as casey
suggested the last few months of boris
were quite obviously the opposite of
unity um and the leadership contest was
drawn out and fractures is there a sort
of widespread sense that now is the time
to to come together yeah i mean there is
a realization that they've got two years
or so to a general election you know uh
anyone who thinks that you can you could
change leader in that period again you
know that is totally for the birds i
mean imagine how the public would react
to that so i think the tory policy
realizes it does need to come together i
i think the big
but i think the mood in the tory party
in the coming uh months is going to be
very much governed by the opinion polls
uh i think one of the challenges for
anyone who becomes prime minister of
midterm is that you don't have your own
personal mandate and that affects both
your relationship with your with the
public but also your relationship with
your own mps you know boris johnson
could always say to tory mps look you
know say what you like about what i'm
doing here and there you know i want an
80 seat majority you can you can trust
my judgment i get the public um liz
trust doesn't have that election winning
record so that will be more difficult
for her so i think i think a lot will
depend on
where the polls go
how things like her big energy
announcement land with voters
uh and i think also
how quickly
she moves to unified i mean katie made a
very interesting point there which is
you know what what the trust team are
trying to say essentially with some of
these junior ministerial appointments is
look you know you're there you know you
could move up if you show that you're
kind of fully on board with the new
regime
and but i think that well you know i
think that how she does that how she
handles it will be very important
katie uh we've been given the impression
very much in the last few weeks that
labour's almost licking its lips at the
prospect of a trust premiership
they saw her as an ideal opponent in
many ways
already in the last couple of days
people have started to say that they
have underestimated her
do you get any impression from labour
people that they're slightly more
concerned than they were
i think they're slightly more concerned
in the sense that when this trust during
the
leadership campaign talked about no
handouts and and there's
no various briefings suggesting that
rather than having a big intervention
and one that she has now decided to do
in terms of capping and
energy bills freezing that price cap she
would do something such as just lots of
different types of tax cuts and i think
that they thought where she'd be very um
strict like that in terms of her
ideology that would be very easy for
them to um attack to criticize and the
fact that she has been more pragmatic
and gone for this big bold intervention
has been as much harder for them to
criticize now we see the new dividing
line as windfall taxes the fact that
there's trust is against those but i i
think they thought that the attack line
could simply be that she wasn't doing
enough and that has obviously
wrong-footed them to a degree and then i
think in terms of prime minister's
questions um this trust again the lower
expectations that you were talking about
earlier on um have benefited her because
she had i think two good jokes um one
about you know labor just seemed to just
pick male leaders from north london
and and the other obviously i'm talking
about taxation and and in fact navy
didn't sound new and because she
delivered those fairly well and a lot of
people said well actually
she has the upper hand in this exchange
and i think just going against a female
leader is a bit different than going
against boris johnson in terms of um how
how much you attack in those exchanges
so uh i think it will be a little while
before kirsten works at how best to
approach um
his interventions uh and attacking
eventually liz truss
well it'll be very interesting to see uh
james and katie thank you very much
indeed
now we're hearing the term trusonomics
quite a lot but what exactly
is it and and is it going to work
um i'm delighted to be joined by julian
jessup who is an independent economist
and one of the trusketeers as they're
known um an unofficial uh but
nonetheless important adviser to liz
trust on the economy
um i'm also joined by hamish mcrae who
is a financial commentator and economics
commentator for the independent
among others
um julian this morning
the big bazooka has been fired
at the energy crisis
the freeze on the energy cap is going to
be
2500 which is pretty high uh the
expectations that will cost the british
economy about 150 billion
um
we fired quite a few big bazookas uh the
british economy uh in the last few years
and yet we seem to be lurching from
crisis to crisis is this the right thing
to do
well i think there are no good options
here but this is perhaps one of the the
least bad um i think it is a bad option
because it is another massive state
intervention in in markets the support
is not particularly well targeted so the
biggest benefit goes to households who
use more energy who tend to tend to be
richer and of course as you say it could
also be enormously expensive but
i also think that given the the scale of
the shock uh coming along the pipeline
uh the government was going to have to
do something big and bold anyway
and by announcing this major package
today has at least lifted that massive
cloud of uncertainty hanging over
households and businesses about you know
what's going to happen this winter maybe
into into next winter
so it's got a massive price tag attached
to it but if it rescues the economy from
a deep recession and you know saves
people for not being able to pay their
bills over the winter then i think that
price is worth paying
hey mitch can i ask you a slightly
political lesson economic question i'm
sorry to do so uh but that yesterday uh
kierstarma attacked uh liz trust from
the off and her first uh prime
minister's questions about um the
uh the this was a tax break for uh major
oil corporations
um and uh and she was letting them off
the hook uh and there should be a
windfall tax and so on and this trust
responded as she has done quite a few
times in the leadership campaign by
saying you're looking at this wrong way
around you're looking at this in a very
left-wing way
do you think that's an effective
argument politically
i don't know
um i think that
we've got two years they have got two
years
to
prove that their competent government
this is test one is this the competent
way of fixing things i think
trying to see this in ideological terms
actually doesn't excite the electorate
what they want is common sense effective
government um and i think they will
reward or the reverse uh in a couple of
years time
julian do you do you think um
in about a year's time people will come
to see the energy price threes as an
effective move or do you think uh they
will just be facing even more problems
on this front
uh well i think it by definition it
should fix this problem because
basically the government has said
however energy prices however high they
go um over the next year or two um the
government will pick up the bill rather
than expecting it to land on individual
households and businesses so um i think
in a sense the policy has to work
because that's that's exactly how it's
how it's designed um you also have to
ask you know what what the alternatives
are i mean interesting as you say that
labor has focused on the idea of funding
it from from a windfall tax but um a lot
of the numbers being tossed around here
you know don't really add up i mean the
the big numbers are about the global
profits that energy companies are making
not the profits they're making just in
the uk
um a lot of talk about so-called excess
profits but all that really means is
profits that are higher than normal
rather than necessarily outrageous and
above all companies will be paying a lot
more tax so if you're a north sea oil
and gas producer at the moment your
marginal tax rate is going to be 65 so
it's not as if the treasury won't
already be benefiting
from higher revenues from from higher
energy prices so um i think actually
this trust is probably right to resist
calls for for further windfall taxes
because i think the priority now has to
be to to reassure businesses that the uk
is going to be continue to be a good
place to invest rather than constantly
ratcheting up taxes on whichever sectors
happen to be doing the best
and julian you are as previously
mentioned at trusketeer um
and the speculation is that among uh
your sort of cohort which includes liz
trust she's been very interested in
economics for a long time from a free
market perspective
um that among your cohort there's been a
sort of learning to love of deficits or
perhaps love is too strong but certainly
becoming far more relaxed about deficits
and and running up
uh government debt in order to stimulate
growth have you personally changed a lot
has liz changed a lot on that front
well i i've definitely been on a journey
and my career started off in the in the
treasury decades ago and i would have
been absolutely horrified of what the
government has has announced today um
even more recently five or ten years ago
i would have been very narrowly focused
on on getting borrowing down very very
quickly but um i think we've learned
that isn't necessarily the right thing
to do so the austerity in the early
2010s probably meant that the the
recession was uh was longer and more
painful than it than it needed to be um
and i think what we're learning is that
you do need to be more flexible about
fiscal policy in the short term to
respond to shocks like this but that has
to be balanced by a credible medium to
longer term plan to get the
the stock of debt down relative to the
size of the economy so you know short
term stimulus packages tax cuts loads
loads of spending but that's fine for
dealing with an immediate crisis but you
still need a longer term plan to
keep spending under control to grow the
economy and above all to improve the
supply side performance of the economy
tax cuts might be part of that but only
a small part there's a lot else that
needs to be done as well
hamish uh do you think uh that um the
markets are sort of warming up a little
bit to trust i mean the perception was
that the markets preferred sunak
and they weren't responding very well to
the to the incoming trust administration
is that changing slightly
i still feel very that they're very
twitchy uh and they'll go on being
twitchy they
read sways of negative stuff about the
uk in general uh and trust in particular
in the american press uh they read some
of it in the british press
i think that's going to take a while to
change i think what changes it is
actually the numbers turning out better
than expected uh and they did from the
uh the pandemic uh the correction after
the pandemic the deficit came down much
faster than than the obr expected and
with these numbers now you hear the
headline of 150 billion
what the government's doing is an
insurance policy you know it's putting a
cap it's carrying the burden above a
certain level it could be 150 it could
be it could be much less and anyway if
you can get the rpi and the cpi down you
can get the headline numbers of
inflation down you get a lot back
you don't have to increase your pension
so much you don't have to increase the
payments on index-linked gilts which are
a quarter of our national debt so i i
think these numbers may turn out to be
quite a lot better than than they look
at the moment
i don't think the markets have yet done
the songs well give them a day or two
so let's wait and see how they respond
in a week or two's time but i think that
um at some stage there's going to be a
return of confidence for the uk it ain't
there yet
julian it's widely said uh among uh free
market low tax uh
type people that um
trusts will need to uh be willing to
confront a lot of political pain
in order to
reduce the size of the state and to let
britain become
a more prosperous and faster growing
economy
in your
relationship in your experience with liz
trust do you think she's going to be
willing to take that pain
uh i think definite yes to that i think
she's clearly somebody who is very
decisive i mean she listens to advice
but she then comes to a firm view and
acts upon it uh obviously she's only
been prime minister for a few days so we
don't have much for track record to base
that on but you know the big bold energy
plan is a is a good start
uh and her previous track record in
government particularly at the
department of international trade was
that she was somebody who to kind of
phrase delivers delivers delivers so um
i would be optimistic that she will get
things done um the conservative
government still has a a sizable
majority in in parliament and i know
there are concerns about
some of the mps who might have backed
rishi sooner being still a bit wobbly
but
at the end of the day i think if she
wants to get things done she will get
things done
she has to deal first of all with the
energy crisis but hopefully the the plan
that she's announced the insurance
policy as hamish put it
is enough to put that immediate crisis
to bed and then she can move on to the
other things another the supply side
reforms in particular uh and the longer
term changes in in public spending that
need to be done you know dealing with
the crisis in the nhs and social care
and state pensions and
on all those big pressing issues as well
julian hey mitch thank you very much
indeed
we've talked quite a lot about the new
prime minister let's talk instead about
the lately departed prime minister boris
johnson who has now left number 10.
i'm delighted to be joined by andrew
jimson who is uh the biographer of boris
johnson the the not quite official can
we call the official biography not
official no no unofficial unofficial
unofficial on the first when i when my
first volume about him came out he said
i'd done quite enough work to avoid the
charge of sycophancy
there were things in that volume and in
the one that's coming out at the end of
this month which which are not um which
you would rather weren't in in them well
the one that's coming at the end of the
month is called boris johnson the rise
and fall of a troublemaker in number 10.
uh i think you have a copy there do you
wanna i do flash it
that's what it looks like
right uh and you worked with boris
johnson at the spectator in fact you
were foreign editor i did i i came back
from berlin
um i think the year after he became
editor and he invited me to be foreign
editor and i went to the thursday
morning conferences and i must say i've
been to editorial conferences at many
different publications but never
conferences where there was so much
laughter
as there was at boris johnson's
editorial conferences and one of the
great things about him actually was he
didn't expect us all to be the same as
him he was a sort of go-getter he always
wanted to get the interview with
berlusconi or mugabe or some
implausibly
um famous
uh and possibly scandalous figure but he
didn't mind if the rest of us weren't
sort of go-getters like that so he he
quite liked having me as a foreign
editor who never went abroad and did no
editing
uh he was undoubtedly still is in many
ways a brilliant journalist uh
the jury i'd say still out on him as a
statesman
um yes enoch powell said that all
political lives end in failure famously
uh i thought i'd stop by asking do you
think
his career has political career has
ended first of all and can it be called
a failure
i think the chances are that it hasn't
ended but of course we won't know but he
has had a gift for putting himself at
the center of the story ever since he
went to brussels in 1989 as the daily
telegraph's correspondent and i think
he'll continue to put himself at the
center of the story he can't help but do
that uh and it's perfectly conceivable i
just oddly enough as i was walking um
over to the spectator i met a
um a conservative backbencher and he
said do you think boris will ever come
back
and i said well maybe i said only if the
tory party's in desperate trouble and he
said oh well we're bound to be in
desperate trouble before long so
that's not such a remote um i mean the
tories were in desperate trouble the
first time he got it and they overcame
their doubts about him and he rescued
them from nigel farage and got brexit
done
so um who knows perhaps they'll need
rescuing from someone else
well i i suppose uh people can and that
do make the case that he's not a failure
because of uh brexit because of the
vaccine roll out uh and because of his
tough stance on ukraine um but you could
also make the case that you know he did
go from having this dumping mandate um
about two years ago
and um
he now is uh leaving not quite pretty
much in disgrace actually he's leaving
as a as a politician with his tail
between his legs certainly
i think this is an argument not only
about what boris johnson is like but
also what this country is like and
i think essentially our idea of liberty
includes being able to kick out prime
ministers when
pretty much the moment we get fed up
with them we don't have fixed terms and
we got fed up with boris johnson we like
our prime ministers to be precarious um
they always are precarious it's
surprising actually that margaret
thatcher for example lasted as long as
she did for the whole of the 1980s
um boris johnson hasn't
at least on his first stint lasted that
long but i don't think that means i
don't think you can judge
i think you can judge political success
and failure simply
in terms of how long someone has served
in a particular office
and in fact he uh actually acknowledged
what he called the i think he called it
glorious darwinianism he called it he
praised the darwinianism of the system
in his resignation speech so he you
would think he'd accept that that's part
of the
uh the way british politics works
yes but he's i i think
he he sees british politics in rather
ancient greek terms a hero is set trials
by the gods sometimes fortune abandons
him and then fortune just as
capriciously may return and smile on him
and
actually voters rather like an
implausible comeback and may get very
very bored with what or or frustrated or
fed up with whatever
um happens next so uh he he he although
i think he's deeply wounded by being
rejected by his own party and that is a
deep wound he also somehow
he he still thinks of himself
in these ancient greek terms which we
would never dream of using but as a hero
who who and heroes do sometimes do the
most implausible things and come back so
he hasn't he hasn't sort of been wrecked
in his own self-esteem and he's not
going to go off and live quietly in the
country and do good work for the local
church
tom bower who's also written uh about um
boris johnson puts his failure his fool
down to um covid carry
uh and character
um where do you rank those three in in
i'm not well i think it's very unfair to
blame the spouse
um
if the failure um
or the failings were boris johnson's
failings not those of
anyone else um
sorry what were the two other factors
that were covered in character
well i think
i put it slightly differently i'd say he
was a brilliant insurgent who didn't
and he could be a insurgent until the
until he'd won the election in december
2019 but after that of course he he was
commanding regular troops he was
commanding the whole regular apparatus
of the state and he wasn't a good
doesn't matter not being a good
administrator yourself but you have to
be a good employer of administrators you
have to tell them what you want them to
do and let them get on with it and he
kept on changing his mind and that meant
that the machine the gear sort of ground
he didn't know whether he was going
forwards or backwards what the direction
what the direction was and there were
some brilliant exploits like the
vaccines but the rules there was also a
great deal of confusion and infighting
in number 10 and that was
um perhaps that was something to do with
boris johnson's character being a
satirist and upturner of apple carts
he he he simply wasn't he simply didn't
take seriously all the things which the
pregish
prudish sort of establishment types say
you must he hates can't and he thought
that all this stuff about sort of sound
administration was probably so much and
certainly about rules that was rules to
him were made to be broken and of course
that was part of his downfall that he
broke the rules and was
and um and had no satisfactory
explanation for why he'd broken these
these lockdown rules himself you said
it's unfair to uh blame the spouse to
blame carrie johnson i'm sure that's
true uh but is it not also an
interesting um aspect of the way the
public feels about boris johnson that so
many people wanted to blame
uh his wife for his failings it's sort
of almost as though the teflon factor
just slid onto onto her they thought it
has to be somebody else because they
quite like him
well people look for the weak
spot and there were obviously a
considerable number of people including
a considerable
number of pundits who couldn't forgive
him for brexit
um
and they and of course they they
condemned him as a liar but had he been
lying in order to keep britain in the
european union i didn't think they would
have been nearly so vociferous they
actually had a disagreement with him it
wasn't all about character it was about
policy was the policy to stay in the
european union or not and this was a
very deep and serious um
question and he he was on the wrong side
of it as far as a great many of his
critics were concerned that is what they
um or what they got more angry with him
about than almost than anything else i
think
you talked about brexit but also i'm
interested in what you say about
puritanism because boris seemed to
uh win over people because he was so
unpuritan and so much fun and so amusing
um but ultimately in the british
character do you think there's something
puritanical that always has to win out
not always has to win out we have
gladstone versus israeli we have the
cavaliers versus the roundheads
the the former prime minister who casts
most light on boris johnson is israeli
he was very disreputable man in his
youth
and caused enormous trouble by rebelling
against
the sober sensible men of business
led by sir robert peel
and
he then
he in in old age he told lord randolph
churchill who is very very i mean
politics was much rougher and ruder than
uh and
randolph churchill was calling the the
leader the conservative leader in the
commons the israeli successors of
stafford northcutt he called him a
[ __ ] and also and many other things
which were equally rude um and
the israeli said to lord randolph look
could you sort of turn it down a bit but
admitted to him that he'd never been
respectable himself well lord randolph
um he had this amazing connection with
the working class but only for a very
short time then he blew himself up then
he died and of course he would be
forgotten were it not for the fact that
his son winston churchill carried on
this tradition of tory democracy a
rather loutish
and flamboyant element in the ruling
class making common calls with the
working class patriotism and improving
the conditions of the workers
and laughing at the middle class prigs
like gladstone and this is this is a
this is a
permanent um division in in british
politics and usually the
the um the people like israeli and
johnson don't last in office for very
long and don't always have very serious
reforms to their credit but they do
there is our nation actually thrills at
least for a short time to that kind of
leadership which you could also say that
winston churchill provided in 1940 in in
in obviously much more serious
circumstances well uh liz truss is uh
often accused of being uh wooden
uh and it's obviously she lacks uh some
of the sparkle of boris johnson if you
like um do you think we we
it's that sort of football manager thing
where you go from uh different types of
personality types
and you end up getting fed up with each
i thought she did well at her first
prime minister's questions and it was
actually
quite refreshing to hear a conservative
making economic arguments and doing so
with conviction and i don't think anyone
has
done that very successfully since
margaret thatcher and she was taking on
the labour party and saying that you
don't you can't tax your way to
prosperity and
um her own groups love that
and
labor of course stands open to the
accusation of being against
the desire to better yourself against
aspiration
and all this so i thought she made a
she's made a strong start uh
mind you theresa may made a strong start
and you can't tell what's gonna once
again what we shall think in a year's
time
you don't think we'll need them 10 years
of labor before people even start to
think about a boris johnson back
not 10 years no
we might need an interlude though but
there are so many imponderables and
actually part of the charm of politics
and particularly politics over the last
half dozen years is that no one no
expert has predicted
what would happen
we've constantly
been surprised and i think we'll be
surprised again but johnson is there as
a big figure
and as the greatest campaigner the
conservatives have had since margaret
thatcher
and they may well regret
not being led by him at the next general
election is he still i'll give you a
chance to wave your book around again is
he still a trouble a troublemaker
um he is he is a troublemaker he can't
help it um but he's a he's a he's a
he's a he's a magnanimous troublemaker
he's not a sort of hater he he doesn't
sort of try to assassinate people um he
doesn't try to get even with his enemies
i mean gove knifed him in after the
eu referendum
so
johnson the front runner fell then
but gove came back as a member of
the johnson administration so he's very
good which is an obviously an essential
thing in politics to be able to make
things up um to have a reconciliation
with or to keep
a an incompatible coalition together
um
johnson managed that for a time but then
it then it um lately it fell apart
andrew thank you very much uh and best
of luck with the book
thank you so much thank you for having
me moving on let's talk about microchips
francis pike who joins us now
has written an excellent piece this week
about how
semiconductors
which are very important to the workings
of almost all advanced uh digital
technology
uh are becoming the latest battleground
in the
global struggle between the us and china
he's here with uh cindy yu who is our
broadcast editor and the
host of our brilliant
chinese whispers
podcast
francis i'll start with you you suggest
that america is getting the upper hand
in the kind of global wall over
microchips could you explain to us how
well i'd say first america already has
the upper hand
but what it's doing is making sure it
continues to have the up up hand going
forward and perhaps even to increase its
advantages
by denying china access to
the best lithography equipment which is
the key technology in chip fabrication
can you tell us a little bit more about
lithography because it's fascinating
your piece about just how small and
incredibly difficult it must be
to
create these films that they create
uh give a sense of how small it is
well to to give you uh an example of
this um
when i was when i was in
living in japan in in in the late 80s i
was looking at uh
fabrication of semiconductors and at
that stage
semiconductors were were being built at
the 800 nanometer scale
now 800 nanometers sounds quite a lot
but actually it's it's 100 the width of
a human hair
but we're now down to
five nanometers
so from 800 nanometers to five
nanometers
over the last 30 years this is quite an
extraordinary uh advancing technology
uh and there is only one company that
can do it uh in in the world i think and
this is this dutch company which most
people won't have heard of but is
actually the fourth biggest company in
europe or something is it not
yes i mean it was a market that was
dominated in the 80s and 90s by
nikon and canon the the the camera
companies that we've we've all heard of
but they lost out in the early 2000s to
this this uh startup uh dutch company it
started in 84 but
really made the big step forward in in
2003 when it when it developed developed
two things one was immersion lithography
which is doing the lithography under
underwater underwater
firstly and also what's called twin
scale
lithography which essentially is
the ability to
prepare one wafer disc for
for lithography while the other one is
is actu is actually being exposed to
light so it's a product it's a
productivity uh technique that they they
developed in their in their machines
which are huge by the way the size of
london buses
and now today america has restricted uh
china's ability to buy
uh
from this company
yes one you know one doesn't know
exactly how they've done it whether they
twisted the arms of the dutch government
or whether they
twisted the arms of asml the the dutch
company directly
but but
whatever's
however that's been done
china now cannot buy the latest euv
machines that's extreme ultra ultra
violet lithography machines
and even if they could steal them uh
they wouldn't be able to work them
because you need so many uh high-level
operators is that right
well
they could i said i suppose in theory
they if they conquered taiwan which you
know is something that we're all
wondering wondering about what xi
jinping is going to do i suppose they
could
they could then steal or steal machines
and reverse engineer them
to use
in china for their uh biggest founder
foundry company which is based in
shanghai
cindy uh we we we know that uh
china has ambitions over taiwan
um
to what extent do you think uh
microchips are a motivating factor
in uh zi's desire to
to take control of taiwan and its
manufacturing
i think one interesting outcome from
america's um arms race as it were with
china on semiconductors this measure to
prevent china from getting its supplies
globally whether that's putting pressure
on the dutch government or the south
korean or the japanese is that actually
china realizes ever more if it really
wants to crack semiconductors it needs
taiwan so i do wonder if the more uh
america basically protects um the
resources of its western allies the more
it restricts this globalized supply
chain the more sediment is tempted to
take taiwan now there are some in taiwan
who as francis has written in his piece
think that
the tsmc which is their world-leading um
fabric fabrication plant for uh
semiconductors is a silicon shield for
the islands but i'm not sure that is
necessarily true because i think beijing
is fully capable of overtaking uh
overtaking the islands but protecting
that particular company and its
manufacturing plants and so i think it
will actually contribute quite a lot to
china's calculations on taiwan i think
obviously there are other factors at
play so for example sitting ping has his
national party congress in just over a
month's time he's not going to want to
rock the boat before then but what
happens after them when he's confirmed
in a third term and to his legacy of
rejuvenating the chinese people
um taiwan plays a very crucial role
after that
francis
in in your piece you suggest that the
cheese imprint might be aware that the
window is closing because he's now
falling so far behind in this crucial
tech race
and that that would
uh motivate him to invade taiwan does do
you think the chinese feel that they're
losing their window of opportunity to
catch up
i think there's a there's a problem here
because yes they could invade taiwan i
don't think the taiwanese would
would do a scorched earth policy and
blur their own uh fabrication foundries
so i think that's
that's unlikely but if the if the
chinese did get hold of
of the the taiwanese fabs
yes they'd have the five nanometer
technology lithogram machines
but they wouldn't they then wouldn't get
access to the next generation machines
now at the end of this this year
um
apple's move is moving to
to three nanometers uh with the time in
these fabrication companies going to
three nanometers and then in
2025 they're going to what's called the
angstrom level now the angstrom level is
is
at the atomic level
that's 110 billionth of a nanometer so
that's and one angstrom is the size of
of an atom say a chlorine atom or a
um
or a sulfur atom is about one angstrom
so you're talking about atomic atomic
scale and you know hydrogen atom for
example is is
0.5 angstroms so
here you're you're moving to whole new
areas of of
technology technology
again the company that appears to be in
the lead on this
is asml
and they're the only company in the
world that
looks to have any chance of getting
getting lithography to this to this
level
and so
yes i mean
xi jinping might be able to take control
of the fabs but then he'd be his
companies would be denied access to the
next to the next generations of of
lithuania machines
cindy uh
francis says in this piece that
america's investing more in its own
microchip
capabilities china has done a lot too um
it's perhaps slightly surprising why has
china fallen behind with its emphasis on
technology is it perhaps and perhaps
this is a horrible slur correct me if it
is that it's become too dependent on
stealing technology so much so that it's
not actually very good at innovating it
well this is something that i asked my
guest um nigel inkster formerly of the
mi6 and who has written a book about
technological decoupling coming down the
line uh in this world um when he came
onto my podcast chinese whispers to talk
about semiconductors earlier in the year
and he made the analogy that unlike
something like high-speed rail which
china is now very good at building and
he says that they stole the plans a lot
of the blueprints from japan
um unlike something like that
semiconductors requires much more of a
finger feel much more of this um kind of
passed down know-how that is much much
harder um to steal or procure otherwise
and so that is one of the reasons there
was also a point about how china through
the cultural revolution really for a
decade um didn't appreciate science and
technology and that is a very crucial
decade in this particular industry that
we're talking about um china now is
pretty pretty panicked about its lack of
progress on this front it's pledged over
100 billion dollars into its domestic
industry and throughout the summer
actually there's been anti-graft probes
basically into anyone who is anyone in a
semiconductor world in china because the
government is thinking why haven't you
cracked this there must be corruption
and maybe there is maybe there's not
because you know it could just be the
government kind of throwing its toys out
of the pram there but
beijing definitely knows it's a problem
and it's trying to fix it and maybe with
a new cohort of people who are less
corrupt that is going to be the way to
fix it but we'll have to see
francis for a tech [ __ ] like me could
you just uh quickly explain
why is it so important
for nations that they don't fall behind
or the superpowers that they don't fall
behind on microchip technology
the reason is that
whatever technologies you're wanting to
develop you need the most advanced chips
and that applies whether it's cloud
computing whether it's supercomputers
whether it's artificial intelligence or
whether it's
genome sequencing for example
nvidia which is the leading
company in the world in in terms of
producing
graphic
processing units gpus
its newest
chip
is seven times faster than its previous
generation ship
so again nvidia's products have been
banned from the chinese market
uh by by the biden administration now
that
means that you know china can if it
can't get access to these chips it can
it's never going to catch up in in in
areas like um you know you know genetic
genetic engineering and so on so it's
not just
uh you know computers and telephones and
and so on it's it's the whole gamut of
high-tech high technology
fraud system sydney thank you very much
indeed
now let's talk about the bbc uh and the
apparently never-ending question of bias
within the british broadcasting
corporation i'm joined now by rod liddle
uh the much loved the great
spectator columnist
and we're going to be talking about he's
just stopped abusing
us i should say about the quality of our
set here at spectator tv uh having
worked at the bbc rod uh you're used to
higher standards of broadcasting um but
in your column this week you talk about
a possible new direction for the bbc um
based on the fact that newsnite seems to
have dropped its bias which you describe
uh
brilliantly as
a kind of broadcasted hamstered garden
suburb slip page of the guardian
that was what it was in its previous
incarnation um it has seemed to change
direction and you're saying it's better
as a result
i think it's much better
instead of having four women debating
and being very miserable with each other
uh uh especially about right-wing people
and the tories uh there's now a kind of
breadth to the interviews you
occasionally indeed see a man um on
uh
them
and uh
i think you know mark urban particularly
um is very very even-handed you know
i've heard a number of interviews where
the interviewee has been
uh quizzed from both left and right
um
which is kind of the way it's meant to
be
it's it's become sharper in its coverage
of politics um
it's more intelligent rather than a kind
of scream fest of of outrage and abuse
and i would put that down to a change of
editor and a change of presenters um
i i think will come as no surprise to
your to your to your viewers which is
that uh esme ren who was the editor
has left and so has the presenter emily
made this and so has lewis knowl or
whatever he's called
they've all gone
uh and so the pr so the program has
become immeasurably better i mean they
need to deal with their production team
which when i met them seemed to be a
convocation of perpetually uh
triggered adolescence
uh uh with with the kind of collective
iq of a small tank of plankton
um but i suspect it's got better than
that uh
the the point being i mean the point i
was making you know i guess the
bbc uh if it was looking at a news and
current affairs program needs to find an
audience for it and it might well think
that uh that a a kind of left liberal
inclined program might be an audience
winner
and it should
my honest belief is that it should be
allowed to do that if that's what it
wants to do but not at the same time
make the pretense that it's neutral but
the whole point of the newsletter uh
business is back in 2010 it had an
audience of close on a million you know
900 000 uh and
esme and emily managed to shred that
down to nearly 200 000
across you know 10 years i mean that is
astonishing
it is an astonishing um
degradation of what was the bb's
flagship current affairs program you
know and and you know we all remember
the good old days of news night my hope
is that they might now be coming back
but
it's remarkable that it was allowed to
go on for so long without someone saying
you know aren't we just alienating our
audience with this kind of shriek fest
um
to which you know esme wren and emily
made this would reply but look at what
our twitter followers are saying um
which is
what the left always does the left
thinks that twitter is the world uh and
undoubtedly they were they were kind of
cocooned in a sort of bubble both within
a new broadcasting house
uh but also in a bubble of uh
of that kind of i suppose there's about
two hundred thousand of them are either
people who watch news tonight who uh you
still watch news tonight who are
perpetually on twitter perpetually
outraged by anybody who ever mentions
the word tory
and will
are relentlessly active i mean the
studies of twitter have shown that those
people do exist
so it got it terribly wrong and you
might ask yourself why didn't they stop
it before
but they didn't they
the bbc can sometimes be very very
defensive
well something odd happened i think
during the corbyn years which was that
um
people on twitter
and that diminishing section of the
public that watch news night convinced
themselves that the bbc was becoming
um dangerously right wing
and this is something you touch on in
your column that emily make this said
recently that it seems to have been
hijacked by a
a right-wing agenda i mean to any sane
person i think that's just nonsense
isn't it well it's it's not just
nonsense it's hilarious but credit to
emily but i'm reaching just about the
only conservative in the bbc which is
robin gibbs on the bbc board
i know about news night
i've been on it before uh i've done
programs for a little little uh
news tonight i can tell you that
there was only one person in the entire
newsnite staff
who voted for brexit you know i mean
that is the level of bias and it
i would suggest it's probably not much
different at the today program world at
one and so on
um
it is incalculably
liberal lefty i mean to an incalculable
degree uh i don't think it's hard
left-wing
these are affluent middle-class people
who want to keep their incomes
when questions of taxation come up
they often become somewhat less
left-wing than these are two
but it's left-wing on particularly
cultural stuff
on immigration on
most foreign affairs but particularly
israel
uh
and
it's been it's been like that for
decades and it was pretty much like that
when i was there but it became
unapologetically
stridently and brazenly like that at
news night for a period of about 10 to
12 years and you saw what happened as a
result the audience left in absolute
droves
do you think it might be just a question
of journalistic intelligence rather than
bias um in that the bbc's always had us
quite strong left-wing buyers as you
yourself said when you were there there
was a strong left-wing buyers now i
don't think you didn't know i i don't
think it always has
oh you don't think it was there
no i think the left-hand bias kind of
uh
grew up during the late 80s early 90s
along with the you know it's the it's
the grand scheme of marks march through
the institutions uh under change in our
establishment yes became a lead rather
than a right-wing elite i think back in
the 70s you could
you could probably say that the bbc was
kind of a voice of small c conservatism
in many ways and certainly
when you look at light entertainment
within the bbc back in the 70s all the
big stars bruce forsyth jimmy tarbuck
malcolm and wiser two ronnies uh all
those all those kinds of people silla
black lulu
cliff richard all of them tories you
know all of them tories
uh whereas today if you look at the
light entertainment
um if if it's possible by what stretch
of the imagination to call joe lysat
entertainment uh you'll find that
they're all
uh they are all tending to the left uh
when they're not actually claiming to be
female uh if they're male
um
what did you think of joe license
much talked about performance on sunday
on laura kusenberg's new show
well i thought it was exactly what you
would expect from joe lysett in being a
not funny and be left-wing
and that seems to be i i think there
must be an interview room a bit like the
room you're sitting in now
yeah
at the bbc where
uh potential comedians for
the bbc are are interviewed and they say
to them uh we just need to check a
couple of things first firstly are you
funny no not at all are you uh
someone who hates a conservative party
yeah i really hate them okay you're in
um because it is remarkable the number
of comedians and performers who who just
aren't funny and i don't think this is
just me
they just aren't funny but they do have
the right views you know uh and you
think of all the great comedians who
don't get on people like paul chaldry
for example
he's a really really good chameleon and
he's almost never on the bbc despite his
videos
and dvds selling out you know selling
masses masses across the country far
more than joe lyceum
paul cheldry sold out the uh
what did he sold out something massive
wembley i think you know i mean
a really big figure and he's he's not a
jim davidson he also has a case too
or a roy chablis brown is a serious and
very funny comedian from our ethnic
minorities but because he can't be
pigeonholed by his views the bbc can't
stand it
do you think you talk about a question
of sport in your column is it just uh
light the fact that light entertainment
now has to be a bit more political
because the culture wars have taken over
yeah well i think the bbc presumably
thinks that i think the rest of the
country thinks it doesn't the the
question of sport thing is
it is inconceivable what they did
it's just
so fantastically stupid but though it
does go along with their defenestration
of andrew neal uh and indeed uh jeremy
clarkson uh in the end you know really
really popular people who may have views
with which uh the rest of us here at new
broadcast accounts don't share but what
they did they got rid of sue barker and
with sue barker he was an incredibly
popular presenter incredibly popular 24
years there they got rid of
phil toughnell
and matt dawson who were the team
captains
and they had a chemistry i mean
christmas sport isn't my favorite
program the only sport i really like is
football
and there was precious little of it on
that program
but they undoubtedly had a chemistry and
they were incredibly popular they got
five million viewers nearly five million
viewers
they get rid of sue barker they lie to
the press and say that subarca wanted to
stand down which subarka then
uh uh immediately
corrected and said i didn't want to
so they lie about getting rid of sue
barker they get rid of matt dawson and
phil tuffnell and bringing paddy
mcguinness and
i need to look this up
hugo mondia
you know who go come on
google money and
800 000 that's how many people watch it
now now in any other
institution or corporation
someone who made that decision and saw
that result would be sacked
you know they would be sacked i mean
that is a it is a fantastically
catastrophic decision to have made
and it also brought odium on the bbc uh
with with sue parker
saying that she felt very hurt and
insulted so it was a massive own goal
rather like the last night of the
promise was a known girl but has anyone
bitten the bullet for it nobody at all
what you're not getting rod is it's
about the kids
yes it's about the kids they're
perpetually in search
of the 18 to 30 uh age group
um
but the 18 to 30 age group find them as
irrelevant
and pointless as the rest of us
beginning to find them
uh then you will not bring in 18 to 30
year olds
with paddy mcguinness and hugo monreal
and sam
you know that isn't gonna do it
um you know and that is not really what
their job is
you know that has never been their job
their job is to provide information
entertainment you know and that is that
that is the point of their existence
they ought to be looking at the people
who actually pay the license fee
and asking you know
what do you guys want
instead of taking this
approach which seems to be drawn from
[Music]
hugh green the previous
director general which is you know we're
going to rub their noses in it we don't
care if they hate it
we're here to make them better people
that seems to be the point of view of
all the adolescents working for the bbc
um with the exception of those perhaps
now in current affairs there is a bit of
a change
which is incredibly welcome
well rod will stop there but thank you
very much as you know the spec tv
audience skews very highly towards the
18-30 demographic
that is it for the week in 16 minutes
thank you very much for watching do
please keep watching in the future
[Music]
you